Hey, welcome to drive time with Shawn, Jason and Skeeter Arnett. Welcome everybody. It's going to be really fun today. How's your traffic? Incredible. Bumper to bumper all the way to Mexico. Weather looks great on the 7s. We'll be right back after these words from smart.
嘿，欢迎收听由肖恩、杰森和斯基特·阿内特主持的“驾驶时光”。欢迎大家。今天一定会非常有趣。你们那儿的交通怎么样？太惊人了。一路上密密麻麻，一直堵到墨西哥。7分台的天气看起来很棒。听完来自Smart的广告后，我们马上回来。
Hey, here's a kind of fun thing. Last night's got to be fun. It's better be fun. Good. No, it's not going to be fun. Here's something fun. Last night's got to be like, uh, what do you want to watch? I haven't seen a thriller in a long time, like a really good one, like get out or member
嘿，这里有个挺有意思的事。昨晚的节目一定得很有趣。最好是有趣的。很好。不，这不会有趣的。这里有个有趣的事。昨晚的节目必须是，呃，你想看什么？我好久没看过惊悚片了，那种真正好看的，像《逃出绝命镇》或像
fatal attraction or something like that. You know, in Canada, it's called get out. They spell it the same though. They do actually. Say it again. They say get out. Get out. Get out.
《致命吸引力》或类似的东西。你知道，在加拿大，它叫《Get Out》（滚出去）。不过他们拼写是一样的。确实如此。再说一遍。他们说Get Out。Get Out。Get Out。
O-O-U-T. And it's like that show that was on Fox. It was House. House. That was a big show up there. O-A-O-A-U-T. Yeah. So you guys want to watch a thriller.
O-O-U-T。就像福克斯播的那档节目一样。那是《豪斯医生》。豪斯。那是那边的一档大热节目。O-A-O-U-T。是的。所以你们想看一部惊悚片。
You and Scotty. You're sitting here. Yes. We were like, let's watch it. There's nothing what's got like high rating because it's, you know, it's hard to find a good thriller. So Jason Bateman, we watched the gift last night. Oh boy.
你和斯科蒂。你们俩坐在这。是的。我们当时就想，我们看这个吧。有什么评分很高的吗？因为你知道，要找到一部好惊悚片很难。所以杰森·贝特曼，我们昨晚看了《礼物》。哦天哪。
It was really good. You were really good. I'm glad you don't have notes. Look how surprised you want to do. I do. Is that locked? Yeah. We are locked.
真的很好看。你演得真好。我很高兴你没带笔记。看你有多惊讶。我有。那个锁上了吗？对。我们锁上了。
So please save your notes. Okay. So no. Jason. Jason. It was pretty good. Was it kind of a gift? It was a gift.
所以请把你们的笔记收好。好吧。所以，没有。杰森。杰森。挺好看的。算是一份礼物吗？这是一份礼物。
It was really, really good. It was really good. We really, really liked it. Well, thank you. Yeah. Joel Edgerton did a really good job. That was his first film he directed. I think it was great.
真的非常非常好看。真的很好看。我们真的很喜欢。哦，谢谢。是的。乔尔·埃哲顿做得非常好。那是他执导的第一部电影。我觉得很棒。
I showed my 14-year-old daughter Pulp Fiction last night for the first time and realized about a half hour into it that there might be some stuff that she might not be ready to see. I just couldn't remember. Like the needle in the heart? Well, it had been so long since I saw it. Did she like a good OD scene? Like where somebody ODs?
我昨晚第一次给我14岁的女儿看了《低俗小说》，大约看了半小时后发现，里面可能有些东西她还没准备好去看。我就是记不清了。比如心脏注射针？嗯，因为我太久没看过了。她喜欢那种精彩的吸毒过量场景吗？比如有人吸毒过量的场景？
You know, but it was pretty tame. You know, parent of the year is still open. So I mean, this, we can submit this. No, I'm going to go ahead and not submit this one. Yeah. My dad won last year. Oh, again. Yeah.
你知道的，不过这其实挺温和的。你知道，年度最佳父母奖的评选还在进行中。所以我的意思是，我们完全可以把这个报上去。不，我还是不打算报这个了。对。我爸爸去年赢了。哦，又赢了。对。
Fifty. Fifty in a row. Yeah. Hey, Sean, look how handsome Will looks this morning. Is that because you're three hours, oh no, you're not three hours ahead. You're in Los Angeles now, aren't you? Because he's drinking some milky kind of coffee. What's going on?
连续五十次。对。嘿，肖恩，你看威尔今天早上看起来多帅。是因为你早了三个小时，哦不，你不是早三个小时。你现在在洛杉矶，对吧？因为他在喝那种带奶的咖啡。怎么回事？
Would you spend some extra time in the Schwitz yesterday? Could you look like you dropped a bunch of water weight since the last time I saw you? Good for you. Gosh, you know what? I'm going to jump in here because our guest is a female today. Oh no. Yes. So excited for you guys to meet this woman.
你昨天是不是在桑拿房里多待了一会儿？因为你看起来自从上次我见到你之后减掉了不少水分。真为你高兴。天哪，你知道吗？我要插话了，因为我们今天的嘉宾是一位女性。哦，不。是的。太兴奋了，能让你们见见这位女士。
She's incredible. She's so incredible. Your balls are going to fall off. She's smarter than all three of us put together, but then so is a trash can full of nothing. She's a marine biologist, a physiologist and an astronaut for NASA. Wow. So, might I add here- A real ding-bat.
她太了不起了。她简直太棒了。你们的下巴都要惊掉了。她比我们三个加起来还要聪明，不过装满了空气的垃圾桶也一样。她是一位海洋生物学家、生理学家，还是美国宇航局（NASA）的宇航员。哇。所以，我能补充一点吗——简直是个大笨蛋。
Wow. Might I add here, she has already been so kind to appear on my other podcast, Hypocondry Actor, which premieres on May 5th. That's 5-5. It's a medical podcast that I host and me and this person chatted a lot about what the body goes through in outer space. And so that's why she was on that show. But here she is-
哇。我能补充一点吗，她已经非常友善地出演了我的另一个播客《疑病症演员》，该播客将于5月5日首播。也就是5月5日。那是一个由我主持的医疗播客，我和这位嘉宾聊了很多关于人体在外太空会经历什么的话题。这就是她上那个节目的原因。但她现在在这——
Are you planning a trip? What? Jesus. But more about her. In 2019, she and Christina Koch were the first women to participate in an all-female spacewalk, which is totally rad. And by the way, she also plays the flute, the saxophone, she scuba-dies, she has a freaking pilot's license, and she speaks fluent Russian.
你在计划一次旅行吗？什么？天哪。但关于她的更多信息是：2019年，她和克里斯蒂娜·科赫成为了第一批参加全女性太空行走的女性，这简直酷毙了。顺便说一句，她还会吹长笛、萨克斯，会水肺潜水，有该死的飞行员执照，而且能说流利的俄语。
But today we're hoping she speaks English. Please welcome Jessica Muir to the show. Wow. Jessica, look at this girl. Wow. Hello there. Hello. I'm so sorry for the language.
但今天我们希望她说英语。请欢迎杰西卡·梅尔（Jessica Muir）登场。哇。杰西卡，看看这个女孩。哇。你好呀。你好。真对不起我刚才的粗口。
I know. That's okay. Right up my alley. By the way, we can talk about water, weight, and space, and if that, what happens with that? You know, I will say, yeah, we can go right to the puffy thing. I do notice that at zero gravity, y'all will get puffy for those little links back down to Earth when you say happy Christmas or whatever, everyone's looking real puffy.
我懂。没关系。正合我意。顺便说一句，我们可以聊聊水分、体重和太空，如果那个，这会带来什么变化？你知道，我要说，是的，我们可以直接聊聊浮肿的事。我确实注意到，在失重状态下，你们所有人都会变得浮肿，当你们准备回到地球进行那些短途下降，或者你们说“圣诞快乐”之类的时候，每个人看起来都肿得厉害。
That's your takeaway. That's your takeaway when the astronauts come back. But I've heard that that is a thing, that it's common knowledge. Astronauts know that. Why is that? It is a thing. It's not meaning more water. It's just because you have this upward fluid shift.
这就是你的收获。当宇航员回来时，这就是你的收获。但我听说这确实是一回事，这是常识。宇航员都知道这一点。这是为什么呢？这确实是一回事。这并不是说体内有了更多水分。只是因为你体内的液体向上流动了。
So you know, without gravity, right now gravity is pulling all the blood down to your feet. But once you take that away, everything kind of comes upward. And so you get a lot more blood in your head and you can feel it. You feel a little bit congested. You get kind of a puffy face. Some people more than others. But usually it's worse at the beginning and your body adapts a little bit after you're up there for a little while.
所以你知道的，没有了重力，现在重力把所有的血液都向下拉到你的脚部。但一旦你消除了重力，所有东西都会向上涌。因此你的头部会有更多的血液，你也能感觉得到。你会觉得有点充血。你的脸会变得有点肿。有些人比其他人更严重。但通常在刚开始时最严重，你在那里待了一段时间后，你的身体会逐渐适应。
I wrote about seven jokes while you were talking. I know. This is such a dangerous area. This is such a dangerous area for all of that. But although now, Jessica, I can say to Jason in the morning, like, oh my gosh, have you just come back from outer space? Exactly. You just put this right into your repertoire.
你说话的时候我写了大约七个笑话。我知道。这是一个多么危险的领域。对所有这些而言，这都是一个非常危险的领域。不过话说回来，杰西卡，我现在早上可以对杰森说，比如，哦天哪，你该不会刚从外太空回来吧？没错。你直接把这招放进你的常用语库里了。
Are you doing a live hit from space right now? Wait, Jessica, I can't be the first person to say your last name is pronounced the exact same way as the space station, International Space Station. Like I didn't realize that until last night. I was like, Jessica, mirror, it's the mirror International Space Station. Well, the mirror space station was separate from the International Space Station. That was just a Russian space station. That was it's not around anymore.
你现在是在太空中做现场连线吗？等等，杰西卡，我肯定不是第一个说你的姓氏发音和空间站——国际空间站（International Space Station）完全一样的人吧？我直到昨晚才意识到这一点。我当时想，杰西卡·梅尔（Jessica Muir），这不就是和平号（Mir）国际空间站吗？嗯，和平号空间站和国际空间站是分开的。那只是一个俄罗斯的空间站。那是——它已经不在了。
Now it's been replaced by the International Space Station. But you're right. They were both space stations. Did they ever consider International House of Space Stations? I tried. I pushed that really hard, but apparently there was some kind of copyright infringement. Just pancakes galore. Jessica, let me just say, so you are an incredibly accomplished person.
现在它已经被国际空间站取代了。但你说得对。它们都是空间站。他们有没有考虑过叫“国际空间站之家”（International House of Space Stations）？我试过了。我极力推动过这个想法，但显然这涉及某种版权侵权。到处都是煎饼。杰西卡，请允许我说，你是一个成就非凡的人。
You're an astronaut. And Sean mentioned you have your pilot's license. So I kind of always want to know. And she's a marine biologist and a marine biologist. So what comes first? What was your first thing in the sort of the site like in that area? Were you a pilot first? Was that your trajectory?
你是一名宇航员。肖恩提到你有飞行员执照。所以我一直想知道。而且她还是一名海洋生物学家，没错，海洋生物学家。所以哪个是第一位的？你在这个领域的起步是什么？你先是个飞行员吗？那是你的轨迹吗？
No, I wasn't in the military. So now the astronauts are kind of 50-50 in terms of whether or not they have a military background or a civilian background. So I'm a civilian. I was a scientist previously. That's the marine biology physiology part. So I was working in academia doing experiments with penguins and seals in the Antarctic and diving physiology and then high altitude physiology and that kind of thing as a scientist.
不，我没有当过兵。所以现在宇航员中，有无军事背景或平民背景的人大概各占一半。所以我是个平民。我以前是个科学家。这就是海洋生物学和生理学的部分。所以我以前在学术界工作，在南极洲对企鹅和海豹进行实验，研究潜水生理学，然后是高海拔生理学之类的东西，作为一名科学家。
But I always wanted to fly airplanes. So I did actually get my pilot's license back. I started taking lessons when I was an undergrad and then had my private pilot's license and my instrument rating. And then when we actually become astronauts, we fly the NASA T-38 jets. They're really cool little trainer jets. And so I feel like I really beat the system because now, you know, my dream was to always fly a jet, but I did that without having to join the military.
但我一直想开飞机。所以其实我确实拿到了飞行员执照。我还在读大学本科时就开始上飞行课，然后拿到了私人飞行员执照和仪表等级。然后当我们真正成为宇航员时，我们会驾驶NASA的T-38喷气式飞机。它们是非常酷的小型教练机。所以我觉得我真的打破了体制，因为现在，你知道的，我的梦想一直是驾驶喷气式飞机，但我没有参军就实现了这个愿望。
So I won on that one. That's so cool. And you know, you heard to Sean early on that he last night, he and Scotty watched the movie and they did some high altitude testing too, right before them. Hey, oh. Jessica, how do you manage the disappointment that your parents must feel your lack of accomplishments? Do you send them really nice postcards in the holidays just to keep their spirits up? You know, if you call every now and then from the space station, it kind of makes up for
所以我在这点上赢了。太酷了。你知道的，你刚才听肖恩说，他昨晚和斯科蒂看了一部电影，他们在电影开始前也做了一些高空测试，对吧？嘿，哦。杰西卡，你如何应对父母对你缺乏成就感而感到的失望？你会在节假日给他们寄非常漂亮的明信片来振奋他们的精神吗？你知道的，如果你偶尔从空间站打个电话回去，这多少能弥补一点，我想。
it, I think. I hope you don't have any brothers or sisters that have to live up to your mark. I have four siblings, actually. I'm the youngest of five and I was always trying to live up to them. So I think that's why I ended up where I am. I'm the youngest of five. I knew we had so much in common shop. Let's look at your accomplishments next to Jessica's.
我希望你没有什么兄弟姐妹需要达到你这样的成就高度。事实上我有四个兄弟姐妹。我是五个孩子里面最小的，我总是试图赶上他们。所以我想这就是我最终走到今天这一步的原因。我是五个孩子里最小的。我就知道我们有很多共同点，肖恩。让我们看看你和杰西卡的成就对比。
There's a podcast. Oh, you got two. You got a medical podcast. Two podcasts. Two podcasts. Yeah. He's got two podcasts. So he's kind of doing okay too, Jessica.
有一个播客。哦，你有两个。你有一个医疗播客。两个播客。两个播客。对。他有两个播客。所以他现在也混得挺好，杰西卡。
So wait. So Jessica, tell us about the, I know this is kind of a boring question, but as a kid, like what drew you to look up and go, gosh, that's super cool up there. I wonder what it would be like to go up there and like what inspired you? I first started saying I wanted to be an astronaut when I was five. So I don't actually remember that. My mom tells me that part. Then in first grade, we were asked to draw a picture of what we wanted to be when we
等等。所以杰西卡，跟我们讲讲——我知道这听起来是个挺无聊的问题——作为一个孩子，是什么吸引你抬头看去，然后想，天哪，上面太酷了。我不知道上去会是什么感觉，是什么启发了你？我从五岁起就开始说我想当宇航员。所以其实我不记得那件事了。那是听我妈妈说的。然后在一气级时，老师让我们像大多数孩子一样，画一幅画，画出自己长大后想成为什么。
grew up, like most kids. And that one, I actually remember drawing that iconic image of the astronaut in the spacesuit next to the flag standing on the moon. And I think I just never stopped saying it ever since then. And I don't know. There wasn't any one particular thing that I didn't meet anyone from NASA. You know, I was in a really small town in Northern Maine, right on the Canadian border. Well, yeah, practically Canadian, I'm an honorary, but that's a separate topic.
那一次，我真的记得自己画了那个标志性的画面：一个身穿宇航服的宇航员站在月球的国旗旁边。我想从那以后我再也没停止过这个梦想。我不知道。并没有什么特别的事情，我也没有见过NASA的任何人。你知道，我在缅因州北部的一个小镇长大，就在加拿大边境边上。好吧，是的，实际上就像加拿大人一样，我是荣誉居民，但这又是另一个话题了。
We welcome you. Thank you. Can you guess my birthday? Your birthday is, are you going to say that it's on Canada Day? Is it really? It's Canada Day. Yeah. July 1st?
我们欢迎你。谢谢。你能猜出我的生日吗？你的生日是，你该不会要说是在加拿大国庆日吧？真的是吗？是加拿大国庆日。对。7月1st？
For real? Yes. Yeah. Well, I think that makes you prime minister, technically. Well, I lived in Canada for three years and it was so wonderful because there was always a big celebration for my birthday. Of course. Wait, where did you live in Canada?
真的吗？是的。好吧，我想从技术上讲，这让你成了首相。好吧，我在加拿大住了三年，那真是太棒了，因为每年我过生日时都有盛大的庆祝活动。当然。等等，你住在加拿大的哪儿？
Just sidebar. Where'd you live in Canada? I did my postdoc in Vancouver at University at UBC. Oh, Vancouver is technically not Canada. Yeah. So, yeah. It's Hollywood North, right? Yeah, it's Hollywood.
顺便问一下。你住在加拿大的哪儿？我在温哥华的英属哥伦比亚大学（UBC）做博士后。哦，温哥华严格来说不算加拿大。所以，是的。那是北方的好莱坞，对吧？对，那是好莱坞。
If you get on the other side of the Rockies there, then it's just a bunch of wingnuts. I can't wait for the letters, by the way, from Vancouver. So you study, you do all this stuff, and then what's the moment where you go where it becomes an option astronaut? Yeah. Well, since it was something that I really planned on or hoped to do since I was five, I tried to involve myself in any kind of space-related activity. I went to space camp when I was in high school.
如果你穿过落基山脉的另一边，那边就全是一群疯子了。顺便说一句，我已经等不及要看来自温哥华的信件了。所以你学习，你做了所有这些事情，然后哪个时刻让你觉得，当宇航员成了一种选择？是的。因为这是我从五岁起就真正计划或希望做的事情，我试着参与任何与太空相关的活动。我上高中时去过太空营。
Not the real NASA space camp, but there was a space camp at Purdue, and my sister was there in grad school. And then I did some programs in college and that kind of thing. So just kind of tried to expose myself to as much of it as possible. But I didn't think that it would necessarily ever happen because we all know it's really a very, very small chance no matter how good you are. So I ended up actually coming to work at NASA previously, like 20 years ago, as a scientist. So I was coordinating life science experiments, the kind of experiments that were the subjects
不是真正的NASA太空营，但在普渡大学有一个太空营，我姐姐当时在那读研究生。后来我在大学里也参加了一些项目之类的。所以就是尽量让自己尽可能多地接触这些东西。但我并不认为这一定会发生，因为我们都知道，不管你有多优秀，发生的几率真的非常非常小。所以我最终在20年以前来到NASA工作，当时是一名科学家。所以我负责协调生命科学实验，也就是我们现在作为宇航员要经历的那类实验对象。
for as astronauts now. I was working on the ground side for that way back then, I was here for three years doing that before I actually went to graduate school. So now I kind of look at it as full circle where, well, first I used to coordinate science on other astronauts, then I went to grad school, did all these physiological experiments in planting animals with certain electrodes and measuring these things, and they were my subjects. And now it's full circle where I'm the animal on the other side being poked and prodded on
早在那个时候我就在地面上从事这方面的工作了，我在这里工作了三年，之后才去读研究生。所以现在我回过头来看，觉得这是一个完整的闭环：首先，我过去在其他宇航员身上协调科学实验，然后我去读了研究生，在动物身上植入某些电极并测量这些数据，做所有这些生理学实验，它们是我的实验对象。而现在一切回到了原点，我成了另一端那个被戳、被刺的动物，为了科学的名义，在太空中这个最极端的环境中。所以这只是我在还债吧，我想。不过你不能，你必须，你只能申请成为宇航员，所以没有人会来找你。
the name of science in really the most extreme environment in space. So it's just me kind of paying my dues, I guess. But you don't really, you have to, you just apply to be an astronaut, so nobody comes looking for you. Right, but there must be a day where like the letter comes in the mail where they go, you're an astronaut. Yeah. So I applied a couple of times actually.
没错，但肯定有一天会有信件寄到家里，通知你被选为宇航员。是的。其实我申请了好几次。我刚刚就收到了这样一封。你收到了？对。我刚收到。你本来不应该告诉任何人的。这还是个秘密，肖恩。肖恩申请纯粹是为了被戳和被刺。哦天哪。
I just got one of those. You did? Yeah. I just got one. You weren't supposed to tell anyone yet. Still a secret, Sean. Sean applied just for the poking and prodding. Oh my God.
等等，我有，我有，我有无数个问题，因为你们都知道，太空就像是我的黄片。我，我太爱了，我可以跟你聊九个小时任何与太空有关的事。我就是太喜欢了。给我们讲讲发射的体验吧。所以当你第一次坐上那个该死的飞船时，你是不是得做一些重大的心理调适，让自己进入一种平静的状态，因为那一定是谁都能经历的最具压力的飞行了。
But wait, I have, I have, I have a million questions because the guys know like the space is like my porn. Like I, I love, I could talk to you for nine hours about anything that has to do with space. I just love it. Talk us through like the experience of launch. So when you're on that freaking spacecraft for the first time, do you have like to go, do you have to do like some major like Zen work and get to like a calm place because that's got to be the most stressful like flight anyone can take.
你可能只是在舌头底下塞了一片安定（Zanny），对吧？然后就没事了。就像飞往亚特兰大一样。对。你在那儿资历挺老了。对。这其实挺有意思的。对我和来说，我是和俄罗斯人一起搭乘联盟号
You probably just put a Zanny under your tongue, right? And it's fine. Yeah. Just like flying to Atlanta. Yeah. And you're pretty senior there. Yeah. It's really pretty interesting because for me, so I launched with the Russians on a Soyuz
飞船和联盟号火箭发射升空的。所以在发射前的很长一段时间里，大约一年半的时间里，我都在俄罗斯学习如何驾驶那枚火箭，而且全是用俄语学习的，这真的非常有趣。是的，因为，你知道的，当时航天飞机已经在2011年退役了，而且我们当时还没有像现在这样的SpaceX。我们基本上从2011年开始就只能独家使用俄罗斯的火箭，直到现在我们一直都是这样去空间站的，但那对我来说是整段经历中最好的部分之一。
spacecraft and a Soyuz rocket. So I was in Russia for much of the lead up like the year and a half before learning how to fly that rocket and doing that all in Russian, which was incredibly interesting. Yeah, because, you know, at the time the space shuttle had already been retired back in 2011 and we didn't have SpaceX online yet. Like we do now. We were exclusively launching with the Russians really since 2011 until now we've been doing that to get to the space station, but that was one of the best parts of the experience
我是说，在那边生活和工作。他们的飞船有多破烂？老实说。它们是不是有点老旧，或者像用胶带粘起来的？你知道，联盟号已经飞行了几十年了。所以它是目前地球上能买到的最可靠的火箭。
for me. I mean, living and working over there. How janky are their spaceships? Be honest. Are they kind of, are they a little thread bear or is it like held together with duct tape? You know, the thing is that Soyuz has been flying for decades. So it is the most reliable rocket available on the planet right now.
所以这，我登上那枚极其可靠的火箭时没有任何问题。而且这很有趣。美国航天局和俄罗斯航天局在工程设计上有很大不同，他们的策略是更倾向于简单、坚固且行之有效的东西。你知道的，他们不会一直改动它。他们有管用的东西，就不需要在上面搞很多花哨的东西，相比之下，你知道，航天飞机。那是人类制造的最复杂的飞行机器之一。
And so that was, I had no problem stepping onto that incredibly reliable rocket. And it is interesting. There is a big difference in the engineering on the American side and the Russian side, where their strategy is more something simple and robust that works. You know, they don't keep changing it. They have something that works and they don't have to put a lot of bells and whistles on it versus, you know, the space shuttle. That was one of the most complex flying machines ever made.
你知道，这也是它遇到那些问题的原因之一，但我觉得这真的很——我觉得我们的工程哲学非常不同。他们就是这样形容我从莫斯科买来的邮购新娘的：坚固耐用。但等一下。可靠。是的。但杰西卡，是不是这样，我总是觉得当美国人、像你这样的美国宇航员谈论俄罗斯宇航员时，你们在太空中相遇或者在之前相遇，无论如何，政治紧张局势，比如我猜它显然会消失因为你们在面对面地接触，但是带着这么多政见不同的人见面，通过他们的国家之间存在如此多的政治紧张关系的美国，会不会觉得很奇怪？
And you know, that's one of the reasons why it had some of the problems that it had, but it was a really kind of, I think we have very different engineering philosophies. That's how they describe my mail order bride that I work from Moscow, robust and works. But wait a minute. Reliable. Yeah. But Jessica, is it like, I always think like when Americans, American astronauts like yourself talk about Russian astronauts, you meet in space or you meet before obviously
是的。对我和来说，这让它变得更加特别和有趣，你知道的，考虑到当时的政治氛围，从历史角度来看，作为一个美国人在那边生活和工作。
and whatever is, does any of the kind of tension that the political tension, like I imagine it's obviously goes away because you're meeting the person, but is it weird to meet somebody with so much, you know, through their country having so much political tension between the United States? Yeah. To me, that made it even more special and interesting, you know, to be living and working over there as an American, you know, given the political climate and also just historically, if you think about it.
所以我们在星城（Star City）和加加林宇航员培训中心进行训练。那也是尤里·加加林（Yuri Gagarin）受训的同一个培训中心，他是人类历史上第一个进入太空的人。而那个城市，星城，其实并不在地图上。它是一个秘密城市，因为他们在太空竞赛期间试图对我们保密。所以知道我们在那里，这是一件非常有趣的事情，你知道，我作为一名美国女性在那里训练和工作，与俄罗斯人在尤里·加加林待过的地方一起。对我来说，这让一切变得更加特别和不可思议。
So we're over there training in Star City and the Gagarin Cosmonaut Training Center. That's the same training center where Yuri Gagarin trained, you know, the first human that ever went to space. And that city, Star City, was actually not on the map. It was a secret city because they were trying to keep it secret from us during the space race. So it was really interesting thing to know that we were there, you know, I'm there as an American woman training and working there, you know, with the Russians in the same place
谈谈你的心态转变，如果你有的话，作为一个在地球上生活、呼吸、行走的人，这种视角的转变。在获得了从太空中俯瞰地球的视角之后，我听人说过，这种视角可能会让宇航员在返回后感到有些分心，因为他们把这不再视为唯一的全部，而只是另一颗行星。
where Yuri Gagarin was. And to me, that just made it so much more special and incredible. Talk about the change to the extent you had any, the change in perspective of being somebody who lives and breathes and walks on this planet. After you had that perspective from space, looking back at this planet, I've heard people talk about that there is a different perspective that can be somewhat distracting for astronauts when they come back because they've sort of seen this as not the end all be all, but just another planet.
是的。这真的很有趣。而且我认为它绝对会改变你作为一个人，我们甚至给它起了一个名字叫“总揽效应”（overview effect），这是弗兰克·怀特（Frank White）描述的，当你用自己的眼睛俯瞰这颗星球时，它本质上是如何改变你的。你知道，我认为对我来说，我在上去之前就已经想过很多这方面的事情，就我所看到的东西而言，这完全是真的。第一个是，你知道的，我一直是一个非常、非常坚定的环保主义者。
Yeah. It is really interesting. And I think it definitely changes you as a person and we even have a name for it and called the overview effect, which Frank White described and really how it changes you essentially as a person when you've looked down the planet with your own eyes. And you know, I think for me, I had thought about a lot about that before I went up and it was pretty true in terms of the things that I saw. The first one was, you know, I've always been a very, a very strong advocate of the environment.
这显而易见。我认为你从太空回来后，不可能不更加深刻地体会到这颗星球是多么的美丽和脆弱，以及我们需要如何保护它。你会看到那道非常薄、非常脆弱的大气层带，你就会明白，我是说，你一眼就能看出它是多么的特别，还有这些连绵不断的水体和土地，那是另一个。他们说从太空中可以看到杰森的水分重量。开玩笑吧。
And so that's just plain to see. I don't think you can come back from space and not have a much stronger appreciation of how beautiful and fragile the planet is and how we need to protect it. And you see this really thin, tenuous band of an atmosphere and you realize, I mean, you can just see how special it is and these continuous bodies of water and the land and that's the other. They say you can see Jason's water weight from space. No kidding.
真的，从太空中。对。是的。是的。光线必须刚刚好。对。光线从来没有刚刚好过。我想，顺着杰森的话说下去，但是那种感觉，你的
Really, from space. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. The lighting has to be exactly right. Yeah. The lighting's never right. I guess, and sort of expanding on what Jason was saying, like, but that feeling, does your
日常生活——我是指更多关于你的人际关系，当然，你知道，对地球和环境的尊重，但仅仅就你回来后开始与人建立人际关系而言，当人们说，嘿，这让我很烦恼。而你拥有如此宏大的视角。这会不会改变你的看法，让你觉得，嘿，没必要为我把橱柜门敞着之类的小事大惊小怪，对吧？是的，这确实是另一个重要部分，那种视角的转变，回顾过去并意识到人类甚至是我们的星球在太阳系和宇宙的宏大尺度下是多么的微不足道。而且我认为，你知道，我经常这么说，我希望每个普通人都能体验到那种视角的转变，因为它确实能让你懂得什么才是最重要的，尤其是当我在上面的时候。
day to day, I mean more like your interpersonal relationships, of course, you know, that sort of the regard for the planet and for the environment, but just in terms of when you start getting back and you start having interpersonal relationships with people and people are like, hey, this is bothering me. And you have such a bigger perspective. Does it change that you kind of go like, hey, it's not making such a big deal about the fact that I left the cupboards open or whatever, right? Yeah, that's the other big part of it is that perspective shift in terms of, you know, looking
所以我是2019年9月发射升空的。当时还没有新冠疫情。我们在空间站上目睹了新冠疫情的爆发。
back and realizing how insignificant even we are as humans or our planet is and the scope of the solar system and the universe. And I think, you know, I say that all the time, I wish that every human could experience that perspective shift because it does make you appreciate what's important and especially for me when I was up there. So I launched in September of 2019. There was no COVID. And we watched COVID unfold from the space station.
当我着陆的时候，在我任务的四个月里我们有六个人，然后最后两个半月里，只有我们三个人。所以上面只有三个人类。我们看着事情变得，当然在一开始，就像其他人一样，我们以为情况不会那么糟，我们看着情况越来越糟。然后突然间我们觉得，我们就像是一部糟糕的科幻电影里的角色，镜头切换到空间站，然后整个星球都被，你知道的，一颗流星什么的给毁灭了。
And when I landed, so there were six of us for four months of my mission, then for the last two and a half months, there were only three of us. So there were three humans up there. And we're watching things get, you know, of course in the beginning, like everybody else, we didn't think it was going to be as bad as it was, and we're watching things get worse and worse. And then suddenly we're feeling like it's, we're the characters in this bad science fiction movie where you pan to the space station and then the entire planet is wiped out by, you
而你们必须延续人类的种族。对。我现在必须繁衍后代，带回文明，我负责让人类物种重新繁衍，但当时上面只有三个人。当时只有我们三个人。对。
know, a meteor or something. And you guys have to keep the race going. Right. And I have to now procreate and the, and bring back the civilization and I'm responsible for repopulating the entire human species, but there were only three people up there at the time. There were only three of us. Yeah.
算算数。三个，三个女性，还是上面有个男性？不，我是唯一的女性。那是，是的。哦天哪。我和两个男人。所以，是的，我懂。我环顾四周，心想。
Do the math. Three, three females or was there a male up there? No, I was the only female. It was, yeah. Oh boy. Me and two men. So yeah, I would know. I was looking around and I was thinking.
这就是卡通片里你变成了一盘烤羊排的那一刻，对吧，对吧。在上面看着下方疫情爆发，那一定，那一定太超现实了。你们是用什么看的？你们看MSNBC还是CNN？你们看什么？是的。所以我们能收到一些新闻源。
That's that moment in the cartoon when you turn into a rack of lamb, you know, right, right. That must have been, that must have been so surreal to be up there, watching it unfold down here. What are you guys watching on? You watching like MSNBC or CNN? What do you got? Yeah. So we get some new sources.
我们不像在地面上那样有源源不断的互联网流媒体，但我们可以接收上传的不同新闻节目，有时我们可以获得真正的连接。所以无论我们要求什么。你们上面有5G吗？没有，没有。抱歉。是的。有某些，某些，旋转的某些路段，感觉就像——当我们飞越欧洲时信号差得要命。
We don't just have a constant stream to the internet like we, like we do down here, but we can have different news programs uplinked and sometimes we can get a real connection. So whatever we ask for. You guys got 5G up there? No, no. Sorry. Yeah. There's certain, certain, certain sections of the rotation where it's like, service
所以你在上面待了，我的数学不太好，但是你，你在上面待了六个月吗？将近七个月。所以我呆了205天。所以将近七个月，去年我们着陆时正是4月中旬。4月中旬正是情况非常糟糕的时候。
is terrible when we're crossing over Europe. But so you were up there for, my math is not great, but did you, were you up there six months? Almost seven. So I was there for 205 days. So it was almost seven months and it was the middle of April when we were landing last year. The middle of April was when things were really bad.
所以我们回去的时候正好撞上疫情最严重的时候，这最终甚至成为了NASA和俄罗斯航天局的一项重大成就，他们要想办法用联盟号把我们接回来——我们在哈萨克斯坦荒郊野岭着陆。然后我们派了一架NASA的喷气式飞机去接我们。但是，考虑到所有飞行规定的限制，他们很难弄清楚究竟该怎么接我们。所以我们回地球的经历比正常情况下要刺激得多，有点像电影《飞机、火车和汽车》的版本，我们先坐了直升机
So we were returning like right into the thick of it and it ended up even being really a major accomplishment for NASA and for the Russian space agency and just figuring out how to get us back in the Soyuz we land in the middle of nowhere in Kazakhstan. And then we send a NASA jet over to pick us up. But you know, given all the restrictions with, with all of the flight regulations, it was really difficult for them to figure out how to even pick us up. So we had a little bit more of an exciting return to earth and normal where it was kind of like a planes, trains and automobiles version where we, we first had a helicopter
——这很正常，但随后我们在哈萨克斯坦的大草原上坐了三个小时的救护车，才到达我们的NASA喷气式飞机，并最终回到这里。但那是，你知道的，非常艰难的转变。在太空待了七个月后返回地球已经够难的了，但我突然在一个全球大流行病的中期返回，我甚至不能拥抱任何人，而我偏偏是个喜欢拥抱的人。你知道的，我甚至不能见人，还是说你内心深处会觉得，你知道吗，我觉得我们挺好的。我们打算就待在这上面，度过这段时间。
which is normal, but then we rode in an ambulance across the Kazakh steppe for three hours before we got to our NASA jet and finally got back here. But that was the thing that was, you know, such a difficult transition. It's hard enough to come back from space after seven months, but suddenly I came back in the middle of a global pandemic and I couldn't even hug anyone and I'm a hugger. You know, I couldn't even see people or was it a part of you that was like, you know what, I think we're good. We're just going to stay up here for, just ride this thing out.
就像我会，你知道的，是的，你在太空中，但与此同时。晚点退房。对。你知道的，让我们看看这事最后会怎么收场。对。我本想呆更久。我绝对想留下来，即使没有，即使没有那场大流行病。其实我当时还没准备好离开。
Like I would be, you know, yeah, you're up in space, but also at the same time. A little late checkout. Yeah. You know, let's see how this thing works itself out. Yeah. I would have stayed longer. I absolutely wanted to stay even without, even without the pandemic. I actually wasn't ready to leave.
我宁愿呆上一年左右。这，这实在是太不可思议了。杰森，你会去太空吗，我是说，你会吗，你觉得你会为了六个月放弃娱乐圈吗？我能收到《Deadline》杂志的推送吗？汤姆·克鲁斯很快就要去上面拍电影了。也许你也可以去上面拍部电影？哦，等等，这是真的吗？
I would have rather stayed for like a year. It was, it was just so incredible. Jason, would you go to space and, I mean, would you, do you think you'd give up show biz for six months? Can I get alerts from deadline? Tom Cruise is going to film a movie up there soon. Maybe you could just film a movie up there. Oh, wait, is that true?
所以你知道这方面的任何消息吗，杰西卡，汤姆·克鲁斯的电影将如何运作，它的后勤保障？好吧，告诉他们，是谁拍的，拍的是什么？我不知道这是否已经敲定，但，但你知道，我们一直在听说这可能会发生。对。俄罗斯人也在谈论拍一部。所以他们可能会抢在我们前面。
So do you know anything about that, how they're going to, the logistics of that, Jessica, the Tom Cruise movie? Well, tell them what, who is it and what is it? I don't know that it's finalized yet, but, but you know, we've been hearing that it might happen. Yeah. And the Russians are talking about doing it too. So they might beat us to that.
我想是汤姆·克鲁斯，对吧？就是汤姆·克鲁斯。而在俄罗斯方面，他们有一些俄罗斯女演员，我想也参与其中了。但我不知道谁能先把它拍出来。我们拭目以待吧。哇。又是一场太空竞赛。这是太空好莱坞竞赛。
I think it's Tom Cruise, isn't it? It is Tom Cruise. When, on the Russian side, they've got some Russian actress that, that I think is involved. But I don't know who's going to get it done first. We'll see what happens. Wow. It's another space race. It's the space Hollywood race.
他们，他们打算在国际空间站拍摄吗？你知道，这是我不大理解的部分，因为正如你们所知，拍一部电影需要的可不仅仅是一个演员，哪怕他是汤姆·克鲁斯。没差多少。所以我其实不太清楚后勤方面。没差太多。我本该知道这个的，但是你们是怎么着陆的？是水上着陆吗？
Are they, are they planning on shooting it in the international space station? You know, that's the part that I don't really understand because as you guys know, it takes a lot more to shoot a movie than just an actor, even if it's Tom Cruise. Not much. So I don't really know logistically. Not too much. So I should know this, but how did you land? Is it a water landing?
不，是陆地着陆。所以SpaceX的“龙”飞船，如果你见过那个载具，那是在水面上着陆的。事实上，我们正准备在几周内发射另一艘SpaceX飞船，我也有参与那次任务。所以我要去佛罗里达州协助发射那个机组。然后不久之后，目前在空间站上的机组人员就会在水上着陆。但联盟号是在陆地上着陆的。
No, it's a land landing. So the SpaceX Dragon, if you've seen that vehicle, that does land in the water. Actually we're about to launch another SpaceX coming up here in just a couple of weeks and I'm involved in that one. So I'll be going to Florida to help launch that crew. And then shortly after the crew that's on the space station now will be, will be landing in water. But the Soyuz lands on land.
所以基本上它是穿过大气层，你知道的，这是一个极其动态的过程。我的意思是，你简直是在大气层中燃烧着穿过。所以在紧挨着我脑袋的这个窗户里，全都是这种等离子体，你周围全都是橙色的火焰。然后降落伞就会打开。所以降落伞会大大减慢你的下落速度。然后联盟号有这些软着陆推进器。
So basically it comes through the atmosphere, which is, you know, it's this incredibly dynamic process. I mean, you're literally burning up through the atmosphere. So in the window that I can see right here next to my head, there's, it's just all this plasma, this orange flame all around you. Then their parachute comes out. So the parachute slows you down significantly. And then the Soyuz has these soft landing thrusters.
所以当离地面相当近的时候，这些推进器就会点火，给你提供一点向上的动量，这就是他们所说的软着陆。而且，你知道的，人们向我形容这就像是一场车祸，因为显然它并没有那么柔和。你仍然在向地球坠落，但它实际上比我预想的要温和。你坐在那个为你量身定制的座位里挺舒服的。其实，这真的很有趣。在俄罗斯，有几个身穿白大褂的老俄罗斯人待在一个房间里，里面有一个
So when you're really pretty close to the ground, then these thrusters fire to give you a little bit of momentum going back up so that it's a, what they call a soft landing. And it's, you know, people described it to me as being at a car crash because obviously it's not that soft. You're still falling back to the earth, but it was actually softer than I anticipated. You fit pretty well in your little custom made seat. They actually, it's really interesting. In Russia, there are these little old Russians in white suits in this room and there's like
小盆子，他们把你放进去，然后在你周围浇筑模具，做成这个定制的座椅内衬。这简直就像是直接从1960年代的电影里走出来的一样。这，这真的是一种。哦，听起来真舒服。然后座椅下面还有小弹簧来吸收一部分着陆的冲击力。座椅会翘起。它会向上移动，对，来帮助吸收这种冲击。
this little bassinet and they put you in it and they pour a mold around you to make this custom fit seat liner. It is like straight out of a 1960s movie. It's, it's really kind of. Oh, that sounds so comfy. And then it's like little springs underneath the seat to absorb some of the impact of landing. The seat cocks. It moves up to, yeah, to help absorb that impact as well.
所以座位确实有帮助，但我实际上对它的柔和程度感到相当惊讶。不过我问你个问题。你是一名海洋生物学家，这太了不起了。你如何谈论你在深海学到的东西与太空之间的联系，它们是如何相似的？你有哪些在太空中做过的实验可以跟我们分享，以及实验结果是什么？因为这对我太有吸引力了。所以我觉得，你知道，这其中绝对有很多相似之处。
So the seat does help, but I was actually pretty surprised how soft it was. But let me ask you something. You're a marine biologist, which is amazing. How can you talk about your relationship between learning stuff deep in the ocean and space and how it's similar and any experiments that you've done in space that you can share with us and the results of that? Cause that's fascinating to me. So I think, you know, there are definitely a lot of parallels to me.
我想这就是为什么我一直对所有这些不同的领域都非常感兴趣。对我来说，这一切都归结于探索、转角去看世界以及保持那种科学好奇心。但真正让我以前的研究和作为宇航员的经历最感吸引的，是这种极端水平。当我还是一名科学家时，我研究的是最极端的潜水员。因此，帝企鹅单次呼吸就能在水下潜水30分钟，象海豹能潜两个小时，它们和我们一样是呼吸空气的肺呼吸动物，但它们可以凭借一口气在水下潜上几个小时
I think that's why I've always been really interested in all these different realms. And to me, it kind of just all goes to exploration and looking around the corner and having that scientific curiosity. But really the thing that's appealed to me the most in my previous research and in being an astronaut is this kind of extreme level where when I was a scientist, I was looking at the most extreme divers. So Emperor penguins can die for 30 minutes on a single breath, elephant seals for two hours and they're air-breathing breathhole divers just like us, but they can die for
。所以我们试图弄清楚原因以及它们是怎么做到的？它们的生理机能是如何允许它们这样做的？然后我与斑头雁合作，这种雁每年两次飞越喜马拉雅山。所以它们飞越地球上最高的山脉，一年两次。所以也是一样的情况，真正的氧气限制。我知道那是什么感觉。我憋气憋了两年，等着威尔干出点名堂来。
it for hours on one breath. And so we were trying to figure out why and how can they do that? How does their physiology allow them to do that? And then I worked with a bar-headed geese, the geese that migrate over the Himalayas. So they're flying over the tallest mountains on the planet twice a year. So same kind of thing, this real oxygen limitation. I know how they feel. I've been holding my breath for like two years, waiting for Will to make something of himself.
我一直在憋气，直到这个节目真正排上日程。我太兴奋了。抱歉，我们迟到了。那是我的责任。那是我的责任。我想知道这个答案。到底是什么生理机能让某种生物能够将那么有限的氧气量使用两个小时？
I was holding my breath till this show was actually scheduled. I was so excited about it. Sorry, we were running late. That was on me. That was on me. I'd like to know the answer to that. What is the physiology that allows a creature to just use that limited amount of oxygen for two hours?
是的，所以这不是单一方面的原因。所以这些动物，例如，那些非常擅长潜水的动物，首先，它们拥有更大的血液容积。所以即使按单位质量计算，它们拥有更多的血液，然后它们拥有更多的血红蛋白——也就是血液中携带氧气的蛋白质，以及肌肉中携带氧气的肌红蛋白。所以它们能够在体内携带更多的氧气，然后它们能非常、非常有效地利用这些氧气。第三点，也就是我们的一些研究发现的，是它们能
Yeah, so it's not just one thing. So these animals, for example, that are really good divers, they have, first of all, larger blood volume. So even on a mass-specific basis, they have more blood and then they have more hemoglobin, the protein that carries oxygen in your blood, and more myoglobin that carries oxygen in your muscles. So they're able to carry more oxygen on board, and then they use it really, really effectively. And then the third thing, which actually some of our research uncovered, was that they can
耐受比我们低得多的氧气水平。例如，如果你听说过在水下游泳前不要憋气和过度换气，因为这会导致浅水昏迷之类的情况，这发生在氧气降到某个特定水平时，当你的大脑得到的氧气对大脑来说太少时，而这些动物体内的这个临界值要低得多。所以它们真的可以把这个极限压得非常、非常、非常低，却依然能游泳、寻找猎物和四处觅食。所以如果你把这三点结合起来，你拥有更多的氧气，你能极其有效地利用它，
tolerate way lower levels of oxygen than we can. So for example, if you hear about not holding your breath and hyperventilating before swimming underwater because you can have shallow water blackout and that kind of thing, that occurs at a certain level of oxygen when your brain just gets too little oxygen for your brain, and that value in these animals is way lower. So they can really push it way, way, way, way down and still be swimming and looking for their prey and foraging around. So if you combine all those three things, you have more oxygen, you use it really effectively,
然后你能耐受低得多的氧气水平，那么显然你就能潜水很长时间。所以这是否也类似于那种，那种把氧气含住的概念，就像肖恩走进房间时，感觉房间里的氧气都被吸干了一样。这是一样的吗？非常相似。是的。
and then you can tolerate a much lower level of oxygen, then obviously you can die for a much longer time. So is that the same sort of, that kind of idea of holding that in that oxygen is the same like when Sean walks in a room, it feels like all the oxygen has been sucked out of the room. Is that the same? It's very similar. Yes.
其中一些动物——这是一个很好的过渡。其中一些动物实际上拥有更高亲和力的血红蛋白。它们比其他动物能更紧密地抓紧氧气。这有点像肖恩。这就解释通了。是的。我们应该研究一下他的血红蛋白。我要停止说他只是抓着更多血红蛋白不放，然后就像是，他来了
Some of these animals, that's a great segue. Some of these animals actually have a higher affinity hemoglobin. They can hold on to oxygen more tightly than another animal. So kind of like Sean. So that explains it. Yeah. We should study his hemoglobin. I'm going to stop saying he's just holding on to more hemoglobin and like, here comes
其中一些动物——这是一个很好的过渡。其中一些动物实际上具有更高亲和力的血红蛋白。它们比其他动物能更紧密地结合氧气。所以有点像肖恩。这就说得通了。是的。我们应该研究一下他的血红蛋白。我不说他只是抓着更多的血红蛋白不放了，就像，来了
Sean. He's about to hold on to more hemoglobin as he walks in the room, you know? What do you do when you're up there for seven months and you've run out of an experiment to do and you're looking to just pass some time, do you fire up a conversation, do you read a book? I can't possibly bring seven months worth of books and TV. It's called Kindle Granddad. That's a great point.
肖恩。他走进房间时体内会保留更多血红蛋白，你知道吗？你在上面待了七个月，实验都做完了，只想消磨一下时间，你会怎么做？是找个人聊天，还是看本书？我不可能带上七个月份量的书和电视。这叫Kindle，老头子。这倒是个好主意。
That's a great point. Can you imagine just turning a page and the book starts floating away? Oh, where was I? So first of all, we don't have a lot of free time because we, particularly during the time I was up there, we had a lot going on. So like you mentioned, science, that really is the main objective of the space station. So we're doing scientific experiments ranging from how spaceflight and microgravity affect our human body, so physiological and medical experiments, also combustion experiments,
这倒是个好主意。你能想象翻一页书，书就飘走了吗？哦，我刚才看到哪儿了？所以首先，我们其实没有太多空闲时间，因为我们在那儿的时候，特别是那时候，有很多事情要做。就像你提到的科学研究，那确实是空间站的主要目标。所以我们要进行各种科学研究，从太空飞行和微重力如何影响人体（即生理和医学实验），到燃烧实验——
even flames burn differently in space, material science, radiation, everything, you name it. So all types of really cool science. And then we also have to do a lot of repair and maintenance. The space station's actually over 20 years old now. So we have to be able to fix the toilet and change the light bulbs ourselves. We can't call a plumber or an electrician. And do we have a structured 10 hour work day? Do we have a lunch break?
甚至连火焰在太空中的燃烧方式都不一样、材料科学、辐射等等，应有尽有。总之，有各种各样非常酷的科学实验。除此之外，我们还得做大量的修理和维护工作。空间站其实已经用了二十多年了。所以我们必须自己修理马桶、更换灯泡。我们没法找水管工或电工。我们有结构化的十小时工作日吗？我们有午休吗？
Yeah. So our day, any day consists of, you know, you wake up, you look at your computer and it tells you exactly what to do, all the information's there. Maybe one hour you're doing it, an experiment, the next hour you're fixing the toilet or changing something in one of the systems. The next hour, you know, you might be doing actually an outreach activity. We might be doing a spacewalk one day. So I was super lucky to do three spacewalks while I was up there when we need to repair
有的。我们的日程，任何一天都包括——你知道的，你醒来，看一眼电脑，上面会精确告诉你该做什么，所有的信息都在那儿。也许这一小时你在做一个实验，下一小时你在修马桶或更换某个系统里的零件。再下一小时，你知道的，你可能在做一个对外宣传活动。我们某一天可能要进行太空行走。所以非常幸运，当我在那儿的时候，每当我们需要修理
something on the outside of the space station. We might be flying, oh, this one's for Will. We might be flying the Canadarm. I was about to ask you about the Canadarm. What the hell's a Canadarm? I mean, this thing. That is Canada's contribution to the International Space Station and it's this large, it's a big robotic arm on the outside of the space station.
空间站外面的什么东西时，我进行了三次太空行走。我们可能在操作——哦，这个是给威尔准备的——我们可能在操作加拿大臂。我正要问你加拿大臂呢。加拿大臂到底是个什么鬼？我是说，这个东西。那是加拿大对国际空间站的贡献，它是一个巨大的、位于空间站外面的机械臂。
That's all they just can tell them throughout us. They also have some incredible astronauts. Tell them, Jeff, first of all, some incredible astronauts from Canada first. Secondly, the Canadarm, which all every Canadian, you know, as a kid, we grew up, you watch this, the Space Shuttle launch and on the Canadian broadcast, CBC or CT or whatever it is, they'd always go in there as the Canadarm, you know, and like, okay. I mean, look, I'm not saying it's not great, but I'm just saying like, Canadians always feel the need.
他们就会在各种地方提这个。他们还有一些非常了不起的宇航员。告诉他们，杰夫，首先，加拿大最初有一些非常了不起的宇航员。其次是加拿大臂，每一个加拿大人，你知道的，作为一个孩子，我们都是看着航天飞机发射长大的，在加拿大的电视台，比如CBC或CTV或者别的什么频道，他们总是会讲到加拿大臂，然后就，好吧。我是说，听着，我不是说它不好，我只是说，加拿大人总是觉得有必要。
Anytime you mention anybody to go, he's Canadian, you go, okay, man, great. Why are you, and I can say that as a Canadian. This is a Canadian on Canadian crime that I'm committing here. But the Canadarm, it's great or it's okay? The Canadarm is great. And so we use it for spacewalks. So when I was up there. Why are you winking at me?
只要你提到任何人，他们就会说，他是加拿大人，然后你就说，好吧，老兄，真棒。为什么你要——作为一个加拿大人，我这么说没问题。这是我在犯下加拿大人对加拿大人不友好的罪行。但是加拿大臂，它很棒还是说马马虎虎？加拿大臂很棒。所以我们在太空行走时会用到它。当我待在那儿的时候——你为什么对我眨眼？
You're saying it's great, but you're winking. Why are you, I'm just kidding. I'm kidding. So when I, so I did three spacewalks, but I was also up there when the other two crew members up there were doing a spacewalk to fix the Alpha Magnetic Spectrometer. And during those EVAs, spacewalks, you know, we have a lingo for everything. Those are EVAs when, when I was flying the arm for those spacewalks. So in that spacewalk, my buddy, Luca Parmitano, an Italian astronaut, and then one of the
你说它很棒，但你在眨眼。你为什么——我开玩笑呢。我开玩笑呢。所以当我在——所以我进行了三次太空行走，但当空间站上另外两名机组成员进行太空行走以修理阿尔法磁谱仪时，我也在那儿。在那些EVA（太空行走）期间——你知道的，我们对什么都有行话。那些就是EVA。当我在太空行走中操作机械臂时，在那个太空行走任务中，我的搭档卢卡·帕尔米塔诺（Luca Parmitano），一个意大利宇航员，还有其中
times, Drew Morgan, an American astronaut, they were actually on the end of the arm. So I had to fly them around and really carefully to make sure that I didn't, you know, bump them into the space station. And then other times we use the Canadarm to capture visiting vehicles. So we have a cargo resupply vehicles that go up just to deliver supplies without any people on board. Those get up there really in close proximity to the space station. And then we use the Canadarm to come, we, we fly the Canadarm over and we grab the cargo
几次，德鲁·摩根（Drew Morgan），一个美国宇航员，他们其实是在机械臂的末端。所以我不得不操控机械臂带着他们四处移动，并且非常小心，确保我没有——你知道的——把他们撞到空间站上。还有的时候，我们用加拿大臂来捕获来访的飞行器。我们有货物补给飞船飞上来运送补给，上面没有人。那些飞船会非常靠近空间站。然后我们用加拿大臂过去，我们——我们操纵加拿大臂过去，抓住货运
vehicle and then we bring it down very gently and very equitably. The Canadarm, it's very, it apologizes a lot. Super friendly. Always saying sorry. And a little passive aggressive. Always saying sorry. By the way, if I was on the space station and I came back, every time I landed back on her, I would, I would demand that they play Duran Duran.
飞船，然后非常轻柔且非常有礼貌地把它降落下来。加拿大臂，它非常——它经常道歉。超级友好。总是说“对不起”。而且有点被动攻击性。总是说“对不起”。顺便说一句，如果我在空间站并返回地面，每次我着陆时，我都会——我都会要求他们播放杜兰杜兰乐队的歌。
This is planet earth. Do a pop up. Sean, do you know it? Jessica, talk to me about like being, doing the spacewalks. I can't even conceive. I mean, I've seen them movie gravity with Sandy Bullock and Sandra Bullock, sorry. And George. Look who's Sandy.
这就是地球。来一首。肖恩，你知道吗？杰西卡，跟我聊聊太空行走是什么感觉。我简直无法想象。我是说，我看过桑德拉·布洛克——对不起，桑迪·布洛克——和乔治演的电影《地心引力》。看看谁是桑迪。
Look who all of a sudden is Sandy Bullock. We don't look like Sandra Bullock when we come out of the space suit. I'm sorry. We're not wearing those little tiny boy shorts and of course, but that's hilarious. But no, what is it like to be out there? Because there's no sound. There's no, I mean, it's just infinity in every direction. Is there a fear that like, oh my God, what if this cord comes off?
看看谁突然变成桑德拉·布洛克了。我们从太空服出来的时候可不像桑德拉·布洛克。抱歉。我们没有穿那些小小的男孩短裤，当然，但这太搞笑了。不过，不，在外面是什么感觉？因为没有声音。没有，我是说，四面八方只有无尽的虚空。会不会有一种恐惧，比如，天哪，万一这根绳子断了怎么办？
What if I, I mean, what is it, what emotionally? What is it like? Yeah. It's interesting. It's kind of like the question that I didn't answer earlier, I guess, about launching. I think all of it goes back to the training that we have. So we have done all of these actions so many times on the ground for the launch sequence in a simulator for the space suit, we're in a space suit, the same space suit, but a downgraded
万一我——我是说，那种感觉是什么，从情感上来说？那是什么感觉？是的。这很有趣。有点像我刚才没有回答的那个关于发射的问题，我想。我觉得这一切都归功于我们所接受的训练。所以我们已经在地面上针对发射程序在模拟器中做过无数次这些动作了；对于太空服，我们穿着太空服，是同一套太空服，但只是
version from the flight version. And we do that in a big pool here at NASA in Houston. So we're so used to all of the muscle memory and everything involved. And our training, you know, literally I trained for like six years before I went to space. So I had all of that mechanical memory. So because you can rely on that training, you kind of just automatically do these things and it helps you kind of separate some of the more, some of the other thoughts you have. So you don't freak out in the moment.
飞行版的降级版本。我们在休斯敦美国宇航局的一个大水池里进行这种训练。所以我们对所有的肌肉记忆和涉及的一切都非常习惯。我们的训练，你知道的，我在去太空前实际上接受了大约六年的训练。所以我拥有所有那些机械记忆。因为你可以依赖这种训练，你就会自然而然地做这些事情，它能帮你把一些更深层、更多的其他想法暂时抛开。所以你在那一刻不会吓坏。
Right. Yeah. But then can you enjoy the moment too? Yeah. Are you just so focused? No, absolutely. So it is really different for different people. I mean, spacewalks are a really special thing where some people, you wouldn't expect it.
对的。是的。但随后你也能享受那一刻吗？是的。你只是太专注了吗？不，绝对能。所以对不同的人来说，感觉真的很不一样。我是说，太空行走是一件非常特殊的事情，有些人，你根本想不到。
You know, some big, tough jet pilot goes out on a spacewalk and is terrified, you know, some people feel like they're falling. Sure. It's just a weird, like you actually, when you're looking out a window on the space station, of course you can feel that sense of motion, but it's much more so when it's just you in a space suit and you look down and the earth is going past you so fast. I mean, we're going around the entire planet every 90 minutes. So you know, you're, it's moving really quickly because you're carrying the same speed you
你知道的，某个身材高大、硬朗的喷气式飞机飞行员去进行太空行走时会吓得要死，你知道的，有些人会觉得他们在下坠。当然。这只是一种奇怪的感觉，比如你实际上——当你在空间站看窗外时，你当然能感受到那种运动感，但当只有你和一个太空服在一起，你往下看，地球以极快的速度从你身下掠过时，这种感觉要强烈得多。我是说，我们每90分钟绕整个星球一圈。所以你知道的，它移动得非常快，因为你带着冲破大气层时
had when you broke through the atmosphere. That coupled with the fact the earth is rotating the opposite direction at what roughly a thousand miles an hour. It's because of the altitude of our orbit. So that kind of dictates your orbital velocity, how fast you're going. And at low earth orbit where the space station is, it's about 250 miles above the planet. And so that's where we're going 17,500 miles per hour. So you feel that more when, you know, you don't feel like you're, you know, moving because
所拥有的速度。再加上地球以大约每小时一千英里的速度向相反方向旋转。这是由我们的轨道高度决定的。所以这在某种程度上决定了你的轨道速度，也就是你移动得有多快。在空间站所在的低地球轨道上，它大约在星球上方250英里处。所以我们在那里以每小时17,500英里的速度飞行。所以当你——你不会觉得自己好像在移动，因为
you're moving at the same speed as the space station is, I'm holding on to it. But when you look down, you kind of can feel that more, but it is. So does that mean that you've, sorry, that you've broken through the atmosphere at 17,000 miles an hour and then you can shut off the engines and since there's no gravity, it'll just carry that speed forever? No. So when you launch in the spacecraft, you're actually in space only after about eight minutes. And so those engines have gotten you out of the atmosphere.
你的移动速度和空间站一样，我正抓着它。但当你向下看时，那种感觉会更强烈一些，但确实如此。那么，这是否意味着你以每小时17,000英里的速度冲破大气层，然后你就可以关闭发动机，既然没有重力，它就会永远保持这个速度？不。所以当你乘航天器发射升空时，其实大约八分钟后你就已经进入太空了。所以那些发动机把你送出了大气层。
And I actually don't even know what exactly that that peak speed is for the Soyuz in terms of the launch. But then when you get out of the atmosphere and past all of that, depending on where you want to end up, what orbit you want to end up in, you'll do some little mini burns. And so of course we want to then rendezvous with the space station. So all of the orbital mechanics. I do a lot of mini burns on this show, just like a little mini, just a little mini burn to get you where you need to be.
其实我甚至不知道联盟号发射时的具体峰值速度是多少。但当你飞出大气层并穿过所有这一切之后，根据你想去的地方、你想进入的轨道，你会进行一些小型点火。所以我们当然想要与空间站交会对接。所以所有的轨道力学。我在这个节目里做很多小型点火，就像一个小型的，只是一个小型的点火来把你带到你需要去的地方。
So when you're up there, do you guys, are you exposed at all? I mean, did you follow at all the whole thing with like the, with the nerd lux and when they played basketball against Bugs Bunny and Michael Jordan? Like did, did that, that's no, well, that's space jam. That's a space jam. But they must have seen part of it when you were up there in space with, no, no, no space jams. That's a cartoon.
所以当你在那儿的时候，你们，你们会暴露在外吗？我是说，你关注过关于“书呆子勒克斯”（Nerdlucks）以及他们在同兔八哥和迈克尔·乔丹打篮球的整件事吗？就像，那——那是，不，那是《空中大灌篮》。那是《空中大灌篮》。但当你身处太空时，你一定看过其中的一部分，不，不，不，《空中大灌篮》。那是动画片。
You know what I did try to do? I, I do have to get this in, I think, because I actually tried to call Will from space. And he didn't, he wouldn't take my call. So this is why I had to, you know, come on this podcast to ask Will Arnett to speak to me. Yeah, this is true. So, so as astronauts, when we're up there for a long duration mission, part of our like psychological support is that we get to ask two celebrities, we get to have a call arranged
你知道我尝试过做什么吗？我想我必须把这个说出来，因为我确实尝试过从太空给威尔打电话。但他没有——他不接我的电话。所以这就是为什么我不得不，你知道的，来到这个播客节目，要求威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）跟我说话。是的，这是真的。所以，作为宇航员，当我们去那里执行长期任务时，我们心理支持的一部分就是我们可以邀请两位名人，我们可以安排一次通话
like a video chat to the space station with some kind of celebrity. And I figured, you know, instead of maybe some kind of world changer, I wanted someone to make me laugh because this was a long duration mission. So I chose Will. World nonchanger. I know. I know. I know.
就像通过视频聊天连接到空间站，跟某种名人通话。我想，比起某种改变世界的人，我需要一个能让我笑的人，因为这是一次长期的任务。所以我选择了威尔。一个没有改变世界的人。我懂。我懂。我懂。
Obviously it was a mistake. He was not available. Did the call not go through? So I don't know. Well, I didn't know your number. So basically the people, so my psychological support people were working at trying to work it through their contacts, but apparently they tried to get a hold of your agent or something, but we never heard back.
显然这是一个错误。他当时没空。电话没接通吗？所以我不知道。嗯，我不知道你的号码。基本上是那些人——所以我的心理支持人员一直在努力通过他们的联系人进行安排，但显然他们试图联系你的经纪人还是什么的，但我们从未收到回复。
So. No way. Yeah. We could have done this from space. When I was floating and my hair was up like this, it was much more interesting. I have to go through his agent to get a hold of him. How mad am I? Thank you, Jason.
所以。不会吧。是的。我们本可以在太空中做这件事。当我漂浮着，头发像这样竖起来时，这会更有趣。我得通过他的经纪人才能联系到他。我现在有多生气？谢谢你，杰森。
How mad am I at Peter Principata right now? Could have been Sharon Jackson. I think that sometimes we might not have the right contacts and then also sometimes people don't think the emails are real. So I did one of mine with Tom Hiddleston and he said that. He was like, yeah, we got this email and we're like, this isn't real. This has got to be fake. But in the end, I ended up talking to David Attenborough instead of Will, so it was still
我对彼得·普林西帕塔（Peter Principata）有多生气？本来可以找莎朗·杰克逊的。我想有时候我们可能没有正确的联系方式，然后有时候人们以为电子邮件不是真的。所以我跟汤姆·希德勒斯顿（Tom Hiddleston）做过一次连线，他说过类似的话。他当时说，是的，我们收到了这封邮件，然后我们想，这不是真的。这肯定是假的。但最后，我跟大卫·阿滕伯勒（David Attenborough）而不是威尔进行了交谈，所以这还是
kind of weird. Oh man. A lot of laughs, you know, from David Attenborough. Okay. It wasn't real. It didn't have the same comic value, but you know, it was still pretty incredible to be looking. Listen, like you're high enough out to do, it's like when you watch a movie on an airplane,
有点奇怪。天哪。你知道的，大卫·阿滕伯勒带来了很多笑声。好吧。这不是真的。虽然没有同样的喜剧效果，但你知道，看着——听着，就像你飞得够高去做这件事，这就像你在飞机上看电影一样，
like you're just, you're goofy enough that you'll laugh at anything. I mean, Attenborough kills in space. Are you kidding? I can't believe an astronaut tried to call you from space. I know. Well, that is, you're done. You can't get better. Well, now I have better context.
就像你足够傻，什么都能笑出来。我是说，阿滕伯勒在太空中效果绝佳。你在开玩笑吗？我简直不敢相信有个宇航员试图从太空给你打电话。我懂。好吧，那就是，你赢了。不可能再好了。好吧，现在我有更好的背景了。
So if I get to go to space again, you know, you guys will be my top choices. Great. This is great. Yeah. We're going to have you, how about this? Next time you go to space, we'll do a live pot, we'll do the podcast from space. It'll be the first ever podcast in space. Let's do that.
所以如果我再去太空，你知道的，你们俩将是我的首选。太棒了。这太棒了。是的。我们要让你——这样如何？下次你去太空时，我们做个现场播客——我们从太空做这个播客。这将是有史以来第一个太空播客。我们就这么办。
That's a pledge. That'd be really fun. I'm in. Hey, I want to know when you're, when you're out on those space walks and you know this, you know you're going to get this question from me, if, if any question. Do you, have you seen any bullshit with UFOs and all that crazy thing? You could say that louder on that question. Sean would like to know if you saw any UFOs up there.
这是一个承诺。那会非常有趣。算我一个。嘿，我想知道当你在进行那些太空行走时——你知道这个，你知道你会从我这里听到这个问题，如果一定要问什么问题的话。你，你有没有见过关于UFO以及所有那些疯狂事情的鬼话？你可以大声点问这个问题。肖恩想知道你在上面有没有看到任何UFO。
And what do you think about the Pentagon releasing all that UFO stuff because it's, you know, you read it, you look at it, you're like, okay, well, that's happening. Well, people ask us about aliens a lot, but it actually, sometimes people laugh, but it is actually a really good question. Cause if you think about it, statistically speaking, there absolutely is or has been life somewhere else, you know, it would be way too egotistical to think that we are the only planet and we're so special that we're the only one with life. So I am absolutely sure that there is or was life somewhere else, but also statistically
你对五角大楼公布所有这些UFO资料有什么看法？因为你知道的，你读了，你看了，你会想，好吧，这正在发生。好吧，人们经常问我们关于外星人的问题，但实际上——有时候人们会笑，但这确实是一个非常好的问题。因为如果你仔细想想，从统计学上讲，其他地方绝对有或者曾经有过生命，你知道的，如果认为我们是唯一的星球，而且我们如此特别，以至于我们是唯一拥有生命的星球，那就太自负了。所以我绝对确信其他地方有或者曾有生命，但同时从统计学
speaking, given the dimensions of time and space, you know, we might not ever actually have proof of that or proof of each other, but it absolutely has happened or will happen. And unfortunately I don't have any proof of it. I didn't see anything special from, from the space station, but I'm sure it is. Well, then this interview is over. This interview is probably over. No, but do you watch movies like interstellar and things like that? Do you watch them and laugh and go, Oh, look at these morons.
角度来看，鉴于时间和空间的维度，你知道的，我们可能永远不会有这方面的证据或彼此存在的证据，但它绝对已经发生过或将要发生。不幸的是，我没有任何这方面的证据。我在空间站没有看到任何特别的东西，但我确信它是存在的。好吧，那这次采访结束了。这次采访可能结束了。不，但你看过像《星际穿越》这样的电影吗？你看它们的时候会笑，然后说：“哦，看看这些笨蛋。”
It depends. So you guys mentioned gravity earlier in that one, cinematography wise, in terms of what space looks like in the field, they did a really good job of capturing that. But the plot was really not very great. But then you didn't buy George Clooney tapping on the window and saving the day. He was hardly in the movie, right? They killed him off really early, which was very sad for me. There's always in those movies, there's always, you know, this magical gravity that's on those
这得看情况。所以你们刚才提到了《地心引力》，就电影摄影而言，就太空的外观和视野而言，他们在捕捉这一点上做得非常好。但剧情其实不太好。不过你不会相信乔治·克鲁尼敲窗户并拯救了局面吧？他在这部电影里几乎没怎么出现，对吧？他们很早就把他写死了，这让我感到非常伤心。在那些电影里总是，总是——那些飞船上总是有这种神奇的重力，
ships that the actors walk around freely and with their feet on the ground. Is it ever possible to achieve some kind of gravity and outer space one day? Technically engineering wise, it could be done, but it's also really, really difficult. So if, how you would engineer that would be, you would really, you know, really big space station, something kind of rotating probably. So I think, you know, in all of the science fiction movies, you know, or even the early books like Jules Verne, you always read about stuff like that. And so I think it is technically possible, but I think it's been an engineering limitation.
演员们可以自由走动，双脚踩在地面上。在太空中有一天是否有可能实现某种重力？从技术和工程角度来看，这是可以做到的，但这也真的非常非常困难。如果你要设计那种东西，你会需要一个——一个真正非常大的空间站，可能某种旋转的结构。所以我想，在所有的科幻电影中，或者甚至是像儒勒·凡尔纳那样的早期书中，你总是能读到类似的东西。所以我想这在技术上是可能的，但我想这一直是一个工程局限性。
So we don't have that, but I wouldn't want that because I'll tell you, floating all the time is so much fun. I mean, it turns everybody kind of into a five year old gear. Just, it gives you this sense of playfulness and levity and you can bounce around or do somersaults or shoot down the module all the time. I remember, I actually, the closest I came, I saw, I saw the dead ones out at Long Island at Uniondale at NASA Coliseum, speaking of NASA. And I was floating the entire time.
所以我们没有那种东西，但我也不想要那种东西，因为我告诉你，一直漂浮着真的太有趣了。我是说，它把每个人都变成了五岁的小孩。它给你带来了一种好玩的感觉和轻盈感，你可以到处蹦蹦跳跳、翻跟头，或者一直顺着舱段滑行。我记得，实际上，我经历过最接近这种感觉的是——我看到死之感谢乐队（Grateful Dead）在长岛尤宁代尔的拿骚老兵纪念体育馆演出，说到拿骚（Nasa）。我整场演出都在漂浮。
It's a lot like that feeling. Yeah. So that brings me to this idea too. I'm so glad you said it because anytime I see you guys up there bouncing around or whatever, I'm always like, oh my God, is somebody's ass going to hit the oxygen? What are we going to do? Like, I feel like you're going to hit something that's going to trigger something because all, everything's exposed.
这感觉很像那样。是的。所以这也让我想到了这个想法。我很高兴你这么说，因为每当我看到你们在上面蹦来蹦去或者干别的什么的时候，我总是会想：“天哪，会不会有人屁股撞到氧气瓶？”我们该怎么办？就像，我觉得你会撞到什么东西并引发一些状况，因为所有——所有东西都暴露在外面。
So why is it, why is the International Space Station at any spacecraft for that matter? Why does it always look incomplete? Can't we dazzle it up a little, make it look a more attractive, get an interior designer in there? Like close those walls up or something. Put the buttons behind the panel. Yeah. Yeah.
那为什么——为什么国际空间站或任何航天器都是如此？为什么它看起来总是不完整的？我们难道不能把它稍微装点一下，让它看起来更吸引人一点，在里面请个室内设计师吗？比如把那些墙壁封起来什么的。把按钮藏在面板后面。对。是的。
Maybe on the movie set that they create for these upcoming movies, they'll Hollywood it up a little bit. Yeah. But why, why, why isn't it more attractive up there? We'll paint it a different color. Well, you know, I think if you look at it, SpaceX is making things a lot more attractive, right? You know, NASA's kind of, we've been doing things a certain way for a long time, but
也许在他们为即将上映的这些电影搭建的布景里，他们会把它弄得更有好莱坞风格一点。对。但为什么，为什么——为什么上面不能再吸引人一点？我们可以把它刷成不同的颜色。好吧，你知道，如果你仔细看，SpaceX正在让事情变得更有吸引力，对吧？你知道，美国宇航局——我们很长一段时间以来都是以某种特定方式做事，但
that's all Elon Musk is making things all pretty and flashy. But aren't you worried about covering things like everything's exposed? We cover things. I guess I don't really know what you mean by that. Yeah. We don't know what you mean, Sean. A toggle switch that can make everything explode. Yeah.
这一切都是埃隆·马斯克在让事情变得漂亮和华丽。但难道你不担心把东西盖起来吗？比如一切都是暴露的。我们把东西盖起来了。我想我不太明白你是什么意思。是的。我们不知道你是什么意思，肖恩。一个能让一切爆炸的拨动开关。是的。
This is not really a thing. Everything's exposed. That's not out there. Elon Musk, he seems, is he too goofed up all the time? This guy, he's talking about doing podcasts. It seems like that's all he does. Does he need to spend more time working on the SpaceX stuff? No.
这其实不是一回事。一切都暴露在外。那并不存在。埃隆·马斯克，他看起来——他是不是一直都太胡闹了？这家伙，他在谈论做播客。看起来这就是他一直在做的事。他难道不需要花更多时间研究SpaceX的事情吗？不。
SpaceX is an incredible company. I'm calling him out. Why am I calling out Elon Musk? He's really a visionary and he has, I think he is absolutely transforming space exploration for everybody. Of course. I'm sure. There's news coming out.
SpaceX是一家不可思议的公司。我在公开质疑他。我为什么要公开质疑埃隆·马斯克？他真的是一个有远见的人，并且他——我认为他绝对正在为所有人改变太空探索。当然。我敢肯定。有新闻传出来。
They're going to actually be launching four space tourists this fall. So now there are going to be people flying a space that aren't astronauts. So it is really changing the whole landscape of everything. And he does things all the time that people have said that could never happen. If you watch the Falcon, the first stage of the rocket land, everybody said that was not possible. Mind blowing. Every time I watch it, it looks like it does not look real at all.
他们今年秋天实际上将发射四名太空游客。所以现在将有不是宇航员的人飞往太空。所以这真的在改变一切的整个格局。而且他一直在做人们说永远不可能发生的事情。如果你看猎鹰火箭的第一级火箭着陆，每个人都说那是不可能的。太震撼了。每次我看着它，它看起来——一点都不真实。
That's what it takes though, right? It takes guys like Elon Musk who are total visionaries who have the money, the resources to pour into things that everybody says can't be done and just go, well, why not? Why not just try, right? Is there one general end game goal for all of the research that we do in space? Is it to eventually explore habitating up there? Yes. I had the same question.
不过，这就是代价所在，对吧？需要像埃隆·马斯克这样的人，他们是真正的空想家，拥有资金、资源，能够投入到每个人都说不可能完成的事情中，然后说：“好吧，为什么不呢？为什么不尝试一下呢，对吧？”我们在太空中进行的所有研究，是否有一个总体的最终目标？是为了最终探索在那里居住吗？是的。我有同样的问题。
Or is it just about going further and further and just kind of, just out of curiosity, seeing what it's like further and further out? Or is there an end game goal? How will we know when we have researched enough in space to answer a central question? The research that we do has a lot of different objectives. And so part of it is just understanding more about what happens to us in space or what happens without gravity on any system. So if you think about it, every experiment that's ever been done in the history of the
还是说这只是为了走得越来越远，出于好奇，看看去到更远更远的地方是什么感觉？或者说有一个最终目标？我们怎么知道什么时候我们在太空中的研究已经足够回答一个核心问题了？我们所做研究有许多不同的目标。所以其中一部分只是为了更多地了解我们在太空中会发生什么，或者任何系统在没有重力的情况下会发生什么。所以如果你仔细想想，人类历史上做过的每一个实验
planet has this one omnipresent gravitational vector as always part of every scientific system. So it's kind of like the elephant in the room. If you suddenly remove that, who knows what different kind of results you might have, what different applications there are. So even commercially, I mean, there are different types of products and materials and plastics and metals being investigated in space because without gravity, you can do different things. You can grow larger protein crystals, which has a huge impact in the pharmaceutical industry. So with a lot of these things, you have a direct impact to helping benefit life on earth.
都有这个无所不在的引力矢量，它始终是每一个科学系统的一部分。所以这有点像房间里的大象。如果你突然把它拿走，谁知道你可能会得到什么样不同的结果，有什么不同的应用。所以即使在商业上，我是说，太空中正在研究不同类型的产品、材料、塑料和金属，因为没有重力，你可以做不同的事情。你可以培育出更大的蛋白质晶体，这在制药行业具有巨大的影响。所以对于很多这些事情来说，它对帮助造福地球上的生命有着直接的影响。
So some of the stuff we do because of that unique environment of microgravity, we can actually do things in a different way, which can have really direct intangible results back on earth, like pharmaceutical development. And there would be an ability to perhaps replicate that type of situation down here on earth. So we could grow the larger protein crystals down here. Yeah. Well, I don't know if you could grow the larger crystals, but what you are able to do in space is understand more about the structure of that crystal.
所以我们做的一些事情是因为微重力这种独特的环境，我们实际上可以用不同的方式做事，这可以对地球产生非常直接和切实的结果，比如药物开发。并且可能有一种能力在地球上复制这种类型的情况。所以我们可以在这里培育更大的蛋白质晶体。是的。嗯，我不知道你是否能培育出更大的晶体，但你在太空中能够做到的，是更多地了解那个晶体的结构。
So then you might be able to make a target therapy. So there, for example, there was a Japanese experiment recently that now there is actually a drug for Duchenne's muscular dystrophy that's in trials right now based on that research. So there are some really direct benefits. Part of it though is just understanding more about us if we want to spend more time and explore further in space. So when we understand more about all the physiological and medical effects on us for a six, seven month mission, of course that has direct applications to going to Mars eventually, which will be
所以你也许能够制造靶向治疗药物。所以，举个例子，最近有一个日本的实验，基于这项研究，现在实际上有一种针对杜氏肌营养不良症的药物正在临床试验中。所以有一些非常直接的好处。不过，部分原因也只是为了更多地了解我们自己，如果我们想在太空中花更多的时间并进行更深入的探索。所以当我们更多地了解六、七个月任务对我们的所有生理和医学影响时，这当然对最终前往火星有着直接的应用，那将是
a three year journey. So understanding more about that. And also in growing sustainable food systems, I think that came from an earlier question too. We actually grew lettuce during my mission and that was so nice because you had something green and growing that you got to take care of and we got to eat it. And then the Russians immediately boiled it, is that right or did I hear that wrong? We didn't let them boil it, but it was a delicious salad and we had to send back half the samples.
一次三年的旅程。所以要更多地了解这一点。还有在培育可持续的食物系统方面，我想这也是之前某个问题提到的。我们在任务期间实际上种植了生菜，那太棒了，因为你有绿色的、生长的东西可以照料，而且我们吃到了。然后俄罗斯人立刻把它煮了，我没说错吧，还是我听错了？我们没让他们煮，但那是一顿美味的沙拉，而且我们不得不把一半的样本送回地球。
But to be able to develop these sustainable food systems, when we go to Mars, we're not going to be able to bring all the food we need for three years. So all these things are really important for life back on Earth and for us. Jessica, with all of your accomplishments and you're not even middle-aged yet, I mean you look like you're in your upper 20s. Oh, keep it coming. This is great. No, I mean honestly, what are you looking to do when you grow up?
但为了能够开发出这些可持续的食物系统，当我们去火星时，我们将无法带上我们需要三年的所有食物。所以所有这些事情对于地球上的生命以及对我们来说都非常重要。杰西卡，凭你取得的所有成就，而且你甚至还没到中年——我是说，你看起来像是二十多岁。哦，继续说下去。这太棒了。不，我是说，老实说，你长大后想做什么？
I mean like how much higher could you possibly reach? And I don't mean that literally obviously because you've been to space. But like what do you want to do? Well I am much older than that, but thank you. I think for me the next thing would be kind of what's next. I noticed right when I came back from space, like I said, I didn't even want to leave. And so I was ready to go back and I was thinking more about going back to space than I was about integrating to this completely changed planet that I had come back to.
我是说，你究竟还能达到多高的高度？我当然不是字面意思，因为你已经去过太空了。但你到底想做什么？好吧，我比那个年龄大得多，但谢谢你。我认为对我来说，下一件要做的事将是“接下来是什么”。我注意到当我刚从太空回来时，就像我说的，我甚至不想离开。所以我已经准备好回去了，比起融入我刚回来的这个面目全非的星球，我更想回到太空中去。
And right now at NASA, we have the Artemis program and we're working toward going back to the moon. And so for me, that was actually that childhood picture that I drew that I described earlier was being on the moon and that would be my big goal. I think hopefully we'll get to Mars in the future as well, but the moon is that next step and I would love to be a part of those missions. What are they saying that the plans are for visiting the moon again, what are they looking to do?
而现在在NASA，我们有阿耳忒弥斯计划（Artemis program），我们正致力于重返月球。所以对我来说，实际上就是我刚才描述的那个我小时候画的在月球上的画，那将是我的宏伟目标。我想希望我们未来也能到达火星，但月球是下一步，我很乐意参与这些任务。他们说重返月球的计划是什么？他们打算做什么？
Is it really to set up kind of like a station for Mars? Well kind of all those things are true. So it's the Artemis program and it was announced by the previous administration. And basically the goal of the Artemis program was to send the first woman and the next man to the surface of the moon. Actually the new administration, the Biden administration has now changed that wording. Just yesterday I saw to the first woman and the first person of color to the moon. So there are a lot of different objectives all rolled in here.
这真的是为了建立一个类似通往火星的中转站吗？嗯，这些说法都有道理。所以这就是阿耳忒弥斯计划，它是由上一届政府宣布的。基本上，阿耳忒弥斯计划的目标是将第一位女性和下一位男性送上月球表面。事实上，新政府，拜登政府现在已经改变了这种说法。就在昨天我看到，要将第一位女性和第一位有色人种送上月球。所以这里有很多不同的目标融为一体。
But really the main goal is to go back to the moon and that is for, to me, three main objectives for exploration. That is just an inherent part of us as humans for science. There is a wealth of scientific data that remained to be discovered on the moon. And then also for all of those intangible benefits, like all the results of the Apollo program, you know, there was this huge burgeoning of all of the STEM fields when we were in the space race. And during the Apollo programs, science, technology, engineering, math, all of those
但实际上主要目标是重返月球，对我和探索而言，这有三个主要目标。这只是我们作为人类固有的一部分，为了科学。月球上仍然有大量的科学数据等待被发现。然后也是为了所有那些无形的好处，就像阿波罗计划的所有成果一样，你知道的，当我们处于太空竞赛时，所有的STEM（科学、技术、工程、数学）领域都迎来了巨大的蓬勃发展。在阿波罗计划期间，科学、技术、工程、数学，所有这些
fields were just, there was a huge amount of resources put in and we're still benefiting from those effects in all different disciplines, far outside of space. So I think we can anticipate that with Artemis as well. And I think they got to clean up that par putt. I think that that guy hitting the golf balls around there. I don't think he's, he's still waiting for that floating way. He's still got to make par on 14. I went to NASA once I stated the sandals at, at Atlantis and it was all inclusive.
领域都投入了大量的资源，我们至今仍在各个不同的学科中受益于这些影响，远远超出了太空领域。所以我想我们也可以对阿耳忒弥斯计划抱有同样的期待。我想他们得清理一下那个推杆练习区。我觉得那个在周围打高尔夫球的家伙——我觉得他——他还在等待那个球漂走。他在第14洞还没打出标准杆呢。我曾经去过一次NASA，我住在亚特兰蒂斯号旁边的桑德尔度假村，那是一价全包的。
And can I tell you something? Can I tell you something? Incredible dinner buffet. We can see guys, Jessica, this has been a dream come true for me and for us truly. I literally, I meant it, like I just, I could talk to you for hours. It's always fascinating to me. I love everything about. Next time you go to space, call me.
我能跟你说个事吗？我能跟你说个事吗？难以置信的晚餐自助餐。我们可以看到，杰西卡，这对我和我们所有人来说都是梦想成真，真的。我真的是认真的，就像我——我可以跟你聊几个小时。这对我来说总是充满魔力。我喜欢关于这一切的一切。下次你去太空时，给我打电话。
I'll take your call. No, no, no, no. No, Will, you're done. I did grow up, you know, watching Silver Spoons and your sister on family ties. I mean, like. I can make sure she's around too. Oh, you're going to rope Justine into this? Yeah.
我会接你的电话。不，不，不，不。不，威尔，你没戏了。你知道的，我是看着《银匙》（Silver Spoons）和你在《结蒂家庭》（Family Ties）里的姐姐长大的。我是说——我可以确保她也在附近。哦，你要把贾斯汀（Justine）也拉进来？是的。
I'll do whatever it takes. I want to call from space. Yeah. God, I blew it. I really blew it, didn't I? You really did. I had no idea that my people, I'm so removed from normal life because I'm just surrounded by people.
我愿意付出任何代价。我想要一个来自太空的电话。是的。天哪，我搞砸了。我真的搞砸了，对吧？你确实搞砸了。我不知道我身边的人——我离正常生活太远了，因为我身边都是人。
Jason keeps pointing out. So then I'm just, I'm so insulated because I'm, I'm too sensitive for this planet. That's why. I think that's a thing. You know, it's, it's a Canadian thing. It might be. It might be. Right on.
杰森一直在指出这一点。所以我太封闭了，因为我——我太敏感了，不适合这个星球。这就是原因。我想这是个习惯。你知道的，这是加拿大人特有的。可能是吧。也许吧。说得对。
What a delight. Thank you. Thank you so, so much for joining us. We could quite literally talk to you for hours because you are so smart and we're so smart less. Nice. Yeah. That's true.
太棒了。谢谢。非常、非常感谢你加入我们。我们真的可以毫不夸张地跟你聊上几个小时，因为你太聪明了，而我们太缺乏聪明了。好极了。是的。确实如此。
You've achieved. And, and thank you for your service and all the, all the stuff and the research you're doing on this planet and way up there, too. And for your patience with our dingback questions and our, and our high jinks. Thank you for, for classing us up about. Appreciate it. You're so welcome. I mean, I, to me, Arrested Development was the funniest show ever on television.
你已经取得了成就。而且，谢谢你的服务，谢谢你在地球上以及在遥远太空之上所做的所有那些研究。也谢谢你对我们这些无厘头的问题和恶作剧保持耐心。谢谢你提升了我们的格调。非常感谢。不客气。我是说，对我来说，《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）是电视史上最好笑的节目。
That's nice. I did watch Will and Grace too, Sean. Don't worry. Don't worry. Go Sean. Yeah. Go buddy. She faxed you, but she called us.
这很好。我也看过《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will and Grace），肖恩。别担心。别担心。加油，肖恩。是的。加油，老兄。她传真给你了，但她给我们打电话了。
Yeah. She was very, very, very nice of you. Thank you so, so much for joining us. Yeah. Thanks, Jess. All right. Thank you guys. Bye.
是的。你真是太、太、太好了。非常、非常感谢你加入我们。好的。谢谢，杰斯。好的。谢谢你们。再见。
Have a great rest of the day. All right. Take care. Sean, how did you? How do you know an astronaut? Yeah. How'd you land somebody so? How do you guys not know one?
祝你们剩下的一天过得愉快。好的。保重。肖恩，你是怎么——你怎么会认识一个宇航员？是的。你是怎么搞定这样一个人——你们怎么会不认识一个？
You know, I spoke to one of our producers, Michael, and I was like, I really want to chat with somebody from NASA. I like the idea too. You sound like a petulant child who's like eating a bowl of cereal and going, I want to have an astronaut. Yeah. And I don't want one of the fuddy daddies. I want someone who's recent, just fresh from space.
你知道的，我跟我们的一个制片人迈克尔谈过，我说：“我真的很想跟NASA的人聊聊。”我喜欢这个想法。听起来你就像一个正在吃一碗麦片、然后说“我想要一个宇航员”的任性小屁孩。是的。而且我不要那种古板的老头子。我想要一个最近刚从太空回来的人。
I want a hot dog and a hamburger and a bag of chips. You'll have nothing in my kit. Name the movie. And I want it now. Name the movie. And you want, I want her to be compelling and smart. And I also want her to be a marine biologist and an astronaut. How about that?
我想要一个热狗、一个汉堡和一包薯条。你休想从我这儿得到任何东西。说出这部电影的名字。而且我现在就要。说出这部电影的名字。而且你想要——我想要她引人注目且聪明。我还想让她既是海洋生物学家又是宇航员。怎么样？
Yeah. Can you know Russian too, please? I got everything I wanted. I got it. Boy, Sean, you're, you know, we got to tally up these guest lists. I have a feeling you just sprinted into the lead there with, with interesting, Jessica Mir. Yeah.
是的。能懂俄语就更好了，求你了。我想要的全得到了。我得到了。天哪，肖恩，你——你知道的，我们得清点一下这些嘉宾名单。我有一种感觉，你刚刚凭借有趣的杰西卡·米尔（Jessica Meir）冲到了领先地位。是的。
That was, that was very, very, very cool. I love her. She's great. She, you know, you guys know, I, I could, I love that stuff. I, I think it's fascinating, endlessly fascinating. Me too. Me too. I could, I could slush Ied all day that.
这真的——真的——真的很酷。我爱她。她太棒了。她——你们知道的，我——我喜欢那些东西，我认为这很吸引人，有着无尽的吸引力。我也是。我也是。我一整天都可以听这个。
Sorry. That's a Russian for listen. Do you, do you think that that's a real story about how she actually tried to call Will Arnett from space? First of all. Kind of hard to believe. Take the disgust off your face. Hang on a second.
抱歉。那是俄语的“听”。你——你觉得关于她其实试图从太空给威尔·阿奈特打电话的那段是真实的故事吗？首先。有点难以置信。把你脸上的嫌弃收起来。等一下。
If you're on a, I said you can talk to anybody. Yeah. You're off the planet. You can call anybody on that big blue ball down there. What number on the list do you think you, just don't weigh you were in the top five or 10. It sounds like I was number one, bro.
如果你在——我说过你可以跟任何人通话。是的。你离开了这个星球。你可以给下面那个蔚蓝大球上的任何人打电话。你觉得你在名单上排第几？你绝对在前五或前十里。听起来我是第一名，老兄。
No, no. You were down in the David Attenborough league. David Attenborough came, was her fallback from me. Yeah. Because you were number 745. He was 46. David Attenborough was like right at the top, he's like, of course the person you want to talk to.
不，不。你属于大卫·阿滕伯勒那一档的。大卫·阿滕伯勒出现，是她找不到我时的备选方案。是的。因为你排在第745位。他排第46。大卫·阿滕伯勒就像是在最顶端，他就像是，当然是你最想谈话的人。
But before that, in the top spot, guess who, busy, okay, too busy to take the call. Wish I'd known. Yeah. She wanted to call me of all the people on that planet. Just don't buy it. There's just no way. There's just no way. And it's so, and it really puts it, talk about perspective.
但在那之前，在第一名的位置，你猜是谁？忙碌，好吧，太忙了没空接电话。真希望我早知道。是的。在那个星球上的所有人当中，她最想给我打电话。就是不信。根本不可能。根本不可能。而且这真的——谈到视角。
You know, it really puts it in perspective that, you know, in the whole unit, literally the whole universe, she wanted to talk to me and it's tough to, tough to be humble. God. This is the last thing you need. No, it's tough to be humble. You didn't hear the phone ring because you had your headset on playing Call of Duty. There's a good chance. Okay.
你知道的，这真的让人明白，你知道的，在整个宇宙中——字面意义上的整个宇宙，她想跟我通话，这让人——很难保持谦逊。天哪。这正是你不需要的。不，这很难保持谦逊。你没听到电话响，因为你戴着耳机在玩《使命召唤》。很有可能。好吧。
God, that's so impressive. No, he probably had his headset on, listening about all his voiceovers, that he's done. Yeah. I don't listen to him all the time. No, you know what? I'm probably too busy reading like Proust or something, you know? That's usually what I'm doing. You know what though?
天哪，太让人印象深刻了。不，他可能戴着耳机，在听他做过的所有画外音。是的。我可不是一直都在听它们。不，你知道吗？我可能太忙了，在读普鲁斯特（Proust）之类的书，你知道的？我通常都在干这个。不过你知道吗？
I think one of the most interesting things about her is in addition to her being an astronaut, she was always, oh, um, a marine. Bye. God, I smelled you a mile away. Smelled your bite. Smart. Smart. Smart.
我觉得她最有趣的一点是，除了她是个宇航员，她以前一直是，哦，嗯，海军。再见。天哪，我离你一英里远就闻到你的味了。闻到了你那股——聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。本集暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。